To Na'vi, or not to Na'vi,
that is the question. "Avatar 2" is much
deeper than its surface-level thrills.
"Let's get it done."
It's safe to say that "Avatar" is a far cry
from James Cameron's days directing "Piranha II:
The Spawning." Not only was the 2009 film's
success historic due to its box office haul, but
it also featured new and groundbreaking special
effects and 3D technology, which were evident in
the world of Pandora. It felt like a world none of
us had ever seen before, with its colorful array
of creatures, unique customs, and inspired visuals
that proved to be a sci-fi feast for the eyes.
But as outlandish as the world of
Pandora appears on the surface,
Cameron and company knew how to ground
it in reality to have audiences identify
more with the motion-captured heroes and
reflect on issues within our own society.
Sure, the subtlety of many of its
discrimination and environmental
allegories are as subtle as a "Captain
Planet" cartoon at times, but nevertheless,
it gave something for viewers to chew
on after the over three-hour runtime.
So when diving into the film's
long-awaited sequel, "Avatar:
The Way of Water," that social commentary would
undoubtedly be coming along with it, especially
with the social and political changes the world
has seen in the 13 years between releases.
While the environmental and imperialism
metaphors are here once again, perhaps
more crucial to "The Way of Water"
is something deeper and more timely
in examining how one's identity
plays into the greater conflict.
"Avatar: The Way of Water" introduces Jake
Sully and Neytiri's biological children
and their two adopted children Kiri and
Spider. The majority of the film explores
the kids and their place in the ongoing
conflict between the Na'vi and humans.
"I need you with me."
While Sully's biological children constantly
try to prove themselves as great fighters
like their parents, it is Kiri and Spider
who arguably have the greatest dilemma.
Kiri is the biological daughter of the deceased
Dr. Grace Augustine, who, although naturally
born as a Na'vi from Augustine's avatar, remains
conflicted over her place in Na'vi society while
yearning to know more about her mother. Spider
sees a similar scenario in that he's the son
of the film's antagonist, Colonel Miles Quaritch,
despite growing up with and identifying as Na'vi.
But as he is forced to tag along with Quaritch
for the majority of the film to help locate
Sully and his family, he remains conflicted
on which side to stay loyal to. Together,
both characters mirror one another as they
struggle with their identities while trying
to figure out where they fit in as Na'vi
people, or if they do at all. Eventually,
how these characters see themselves individually
makes its way into the grander story being told.
Just as the first film comments on our
treatment of the forest landscapes around us,
it's probably not rocket science to figure
out what natural environment "Avatar:
The Way of Water" chooses to highlight.
But the film's examination of how we
should protect our seas also blends with
its themes about identity. Kiri is perhaps
the most prominent example of this, as the
teenager is established early on as having
an especially close bond with the natural
world around her that's shrouded in mystery.
When she and Sully's family make it to the
Metkayina tribe and begin learning their ways,
Kiri is once again at one with her environment,
connecting with the sea creatures and world
profoundly. Her abilities come in handy
towards the end, where she communicates
with the sea life to help save her family
from certain death in Quaritch's ship.
Her love for the environment around her
teaches us how to respect this resource
better and how the Na'vi people can learn
from her to settle this conflict. Similarly,
Spider's love for both the Na'vi
and his antagonistic father could
help change the viewpoints of
everyone involved in the war.
In the end, James Cameron's film acts as
more than a simple environmental message,
but an examination of using your
unique viewpoint of the world to
fight for what's right and how
that can help turn the tide.